si vous avez une petite faim c'est
l'heure du goûter ça s'appelle de la
sonel elle est honnête c'est le fruit de
l'aubépine donc l'homme préhistorique
c'est ce qu'ils mangent et c'est parti
pour une après midi découverte entre
professeurs des écoles
il va y en a plus beaucoup donc voilà
c'est pareil c'est une espèce menacée
cette année à travers son jeu concours
l'association yvelines environnement va
faire découvrir les prairies et leur
écosystème
notre but est de donner aux enseignants
et aux centres aérés du département les
éléments qui leur permettent une
réflexion sur un thème d'environnement
nous avons choisi la prairie car la
prairie est un écosystème qui est
particulièrement riche
le rendez-vous permet de former et de
faire connaître aux enseignants un
nouvel univers
j'adore mes appris beaucoup sur
l'écosystème des prairies vraiment toute
cette biodiversité qu'on peut avoir tout
je savais pas qu'il y avait beaucoup de
preuves et qui était fait
artificiellement pour moi c'était
vraiment du 100% naturels souvent
friands de ces ateliers
ils vont ainsi travailler de manière
ludique avec leur classe tout en les
sensibilisant aux questions
environnementales
il ya toujours une dimension écologique
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire nous en tant
qu'enfant qu'est ce qui se passe comment
vous avez faire vous quand vous allez
vous promener donc parler de bas de page
jeter les déchets des petites choses
comme ça les professeurs ont encore
quelques semaines pour préparer les
travaux qu'ils feront avec leur classe
le concours se tiendra du 11 janvier au
7 avril prochain